ich stelle jetzt die
eine-million-euro-frage der deutschen
corona politik kann man ungeimpfte
tatsächlich jetzt noch massenweise zum
impfen bringen geht das überhaupt noch
die regierung hat auf diese frage bisher
keine antwort merkel nicht sparen nicht
scholz nicht kriegt man im verweigerer
tatsächlich jetzt noch an die impf nadel
die wichtigste frage der deutschen
corona politik und ich sogar eine
antwort hat aber weiß
der hashtag alles in den armen haben sie
davon gehört irgendwas gesehen das war
eine twitter aktion bei der politiker
journalisten schauspieler mit ihrer
impfung angegeben haben so wie zum
beispiel die spd chefin saskia esken sie
schreibt bei twitter das hier hallo ich
bin saskia esken bin doppelt geimpft ich
taste mich regelmäßig ich trage maske
halte abstand vernünftige schützen sich
und halten zusammen was für ein
unerträglicher tweet wie ich finde es
ist der tod einer frau die sich offenbar
für besseren menschen hält die die welt
einteilt in vernünftige und
unvernünftige und die auch von oben
herab auf ihre eigenen wähler blickt und
vor allen dingen ist das wie ich finde
ein sinnloser tweet oder fresken dachten
sie allen ernstes dass sie mit der
teilnahme an dieser aktion mit diesem
tweet tatsächlich einen einzigen
impfverweigerer dazu bringen sich impfen
zu lassen das wäre ja absurd das ist das
gegenteil passiert durch diese aktion
kein einziger der sich bisher nicht
impfen lassen wollte sagt jetzt okay
jetzt bin ich überzeugt jetzt lasse ich
mich impfen nein
tatsache ist dass diese aktion dieser
hashtag alles in den arm die spaltung
zwischen ungeimpften und geimpften noch
vergrößert hat den hass zwischen
geimpften und ungeimpften weiter
verstärkt
also nochmal die eine-million-euro-frage
der deutschen kona politik kann man
tatsächlich all die menschen die sich
bisher noch nicht haben impfen lassen
jetzt doch noch vom impfen überzeugen
wie soll das gehen so jedenfalls
klappt's nicht ich bitte sie machen sie
mit und versuchen sie auch verwandte und
freunde zu überzeugen bitte machen sie
mit bitte lassen sie sich impfen lassen
sie sich impfen jetzt ja das sind wir
immer selben appelle die wir
mittlerweile von der regierung seit
vielen monaten hören und die im grunde
nichts gebracht haben diese appelle
haben die impfquote wirklich nicht in
die höhe getrieben und es ist auch
völlig klar warum weil diese appelle
sollen ausgerechnet ja die menschen
erreichen die sich von diesen leuten von
diesen politikern längst abgewandt haben
die werden sich nicht von diesen
regierungspolitikern überzeugen lassen
zum impfen zu gehen ist doch völlig klar
also hat die bundesregierung ein
bisschen versucht druck auszuüben auf
die ungeimpften in den vergangenen
wochen sie hat begonnen erstmal 3g
einzuführen jetzt dann zweig einzuführen
also sozusagen den lockdown für
ungeimpfte hilft das treibt dieser druck
die impfquote in die höhe das zeigt
diese grafik und die stammt von der
bundesregierung selbst aus ihrem
lagebericht den der krisenstab jeden tag
anfertigt hier sehen wir alle im zahlen
des vergangenen jahres der vergangenen
monate die hohen balken im frühjahr im
sommer und mittlerweile sind wir hier
bei relativ kleinen balken gelandet das
ist die letzte woche das ist die zahl
der impfungen in deutschland in der
vergangenen woche der hellgrüne anteil
an diesen balken der zeigt die booster
impfung also die dritte impfung die
leute die schon durch geimpft sind und
sich jetzt den dritten schuss abholen
und dieser dunkelgrüne balken der zeigt
die erstimpfung der s mini kleinen kaum
zu sehen selbst wenn die kamera nah dran
geht also kaum jemand in deutschland
aktuell lässt sich noch erst impfen da
ist kaum bewegung drin trotzdem kampagne
trotz druck und das sagt auch diese
würde zahlen grafik der bundesregierung
hier ist alles an daten drauf was die
bundesregierung zum impfen aktuell
sammelkonto aus allen bundesländern und
da will ich ihnen zwei zahlen zeigen
nämlich einmal
diese rechte spalte die zeigt wie viel
dynamik aktuell drin ist bei den booster
impfung
50 prozent plus 28 prozent plus 50
prozent in den verschiedenen
bundesländern also die leute rennen zum
boostern die impfzentren im moment ein
und dann zum vergleich diese zahlen 3
hier so viel oder so wenig dynamik ist
nämlich aktuell drin bei den erste
impfung 0,4 prozent 0,6 prozent
bundesweit 0,5 prozent winzige zahlen
die aktuell dazu kommen bei den erste
impfung aktuell 40.000 menschen etwa pro
woche da tut sich kaum was heißt also
wer sich bisher nicht impfen lassen
wollte der will das immer noch nicht die
impfquote verharrt also stagniert gibt
es also möglicherweise gar nicht die
chance die leute noch zum impfen zu
bringen die sich bisher verweigert haben
darüber spreche ich jetzt mit mario
czaja er ist chef des berliner roten
kreuzes er hatte also hier in berlin die
impfzentren organisiert und er will
jetzt cdu-generalsekretär werden
ja herzlich willkommen herr meyer hallo
guten tag kennen sie jemanden der noch
nicht geimpft ist ja kenne ich im
privaten umfeld im beruflichen im
privaten und im beruflichen umfeld ja
schämt er sich würde er das öffentlich
sagen derjenige oder diejenige also die
die ich kenne die aus thüringen sind die
wunde ist glaube ich auch öffentlich
sagen die ihnen die aus berlin kennen
wir uns glaube ich nicht sagen und
führen sich momentan ziemlich unter
druck gesetzt aber haben eher den
eindruck sich weiter nicht impfen zu
lassen ich glaube es ist echt schwer
jetzt noch menschen vom impfen zu
überzeugen das ist genau das thema
würden sie sich zutrauen den einen oder
anderen von denen die sie kennen die
eben noch nicht geimpft sind zu
überzeugen also ich glaube ich habe
schon den einen oder anderen überzeugt
wenn man mit krankenhäusern mit
rettungsstellen mit vor allem mit der
intensivmediziner telefoniert ich bin ja
ehrenamtlich noch drk-präsident in
berlin und
weil sie dann immer auf viele dinge hin
aber manchen bekommt man überzeugt ich
habe aber den eindruck dass druck da
alleine nicht hilft sondern dass man mit
unterschiedlichen argumenten mit
vernunft versuchen muss das ist in der
tat das ist ja irgendwie festgefahren
also diejenigen die sich bisher nicht
haben impfen lassen von denen kommen
täglich nur noch ganz ganz wenige dazu
sich dann eben doch im zu lassen also
wie kriegt man die dann was wir die
beste strategie also meine erfahrung war
dass wir als wir vom deutschen roten
kreuz die immobilien im teams hatten und
beispielsweise vorher in berlin vor dem
don juan center werden wo viele
vietnamesen sind
keine niedergelassenen hausarzt haben
die normalerweise auch so wenig die
gesundheitliche infrastruktur nutzen
müssen dass diese erreichbar waren aber
das ist der dass ein zäher kampf um
jeden einzelnen ihn zu überzeugen
aufklärungsarbeit und an den orten zu
sein wo er normalerweise eben auch im
alltag ist zum beispiel an so einem
großmarkt noch einmal die klare
strategie wie macht man ungeimpfte zu
kämpfen was müsste auf dem plakat
draufstehen wie müsste der spot aussehen
was müsste man wie müsste man mit diesen
menschen reden ich glaube dass plakate
und spots nicht helfen sondern das
impfangebot bei denen zu haben die noch
erreichbar sind davon gibt es auch noch
einige die erreichbar sind und an
ansonsten glaube ich einfach auf die
situation in der intensivmedizin
hinweisen wir sind ja häufig menschen
die der meinung sind wenn ich selber
erkrankt wird ist es nicht so schlimm
und wenn jemand geimpft ist ist ja auch
in der lage jemand anders anzustecken
und erinnert so viele unterschiedliche
argumente zusammengeworfen die so im
einzelnen gar nicht stimmen
das ist eins zu eins arbeit das kann man
nicht mit plakaten und kampagnen
erreichen sind sie schon drei mal
geimpft also gepustet
nur zweimal weil die sechs monate sind
auch noch nicht um das heißt die
auffrischungsimpfung die kommt bei mir
ende november danke für das gespräch
mario czaja der hier immer noch chef
präsident des berliner roten kreuzes ist
und cdu-generalsekretär werden möchte
und ich will ihnen eine ganz besondere
idee noch mit vorstellen die gerade aus
wien nämlich kommt da macht man sich
ganz besondere gedanken wie man die
menschen noch zum erst impfen begeistern
kann und ein wiener bordell chef hat
gesagt bei mir gibt's die impfung und
als gegenleistung 6
dann begrüße ich herzlich bei bild den
wiener bordell chef peter las caris
fallersleben
hellas caris ihr versprechen lautet für
eine impfung gibt es sex war das
erfolgreich war sehr erfolgreich weil
sex sells das ist mir klar das muss man
gar nicht in frage stellt bei uns
bekommt der kunde nach der impfung
allerdings nicht sechs sondern einen
gratis eintritt ins modell wären 40 euro
damit er da also viel spaß haben kann ok
es läuft ungefähr aufs selbe hinaus
können sie beziffern wie viele männer
sie dadurch zum impfen gebracht haben
bis jetzt stehen wir bei 300 okay das
ist schon mal ein erfolg wir sind in
dieser corona krise ist gewohnt dass
alles was in österreich passiert zwei
wochen später auch in deutschland
passiert also wollen sie auch
diesbezüglich das vorbild für uns
deutsche sein ich hoffe doch dass wir
diesen kleines baby ziehen da ich mich
besser als eine bratwurst oder ein
päckchen zigaretten zu bekommen also ich
glaube dass das die männer schon
wesentlich mehr
motiviert
wobei die bratwurst riesenerfolg war
schon in deutschland dank alaska
ihre idee da aus wien von der wir ihnen
so gerne erzählen wollten aber es muss
doch noch seriöse
kreative ideen geben um im verweigerer
ungeimpfte jetzt noch davon zu
überzeugen sich impfen zu lassen über
solche ideen möchte sprechen mit einem
mann dessen berufes ist ideen zu haben
und der schon ganz andere viel größere
sachen geschafft hat er hat nämlich zum
beispiel geschafft olaf scholz zum
wahlsieger zu machen zum beispiel mit
diesem plakat ihr dass er erfunden hat
und von ihm stammt auch ein anderes
plakat von mallorca nämlich mit dem hat
er gleichzeitig fürs impfen und noch für
die spd geworben und beides damals auf
mallorca ganz erfolgreich der mann der
heißt raphael brinkert möchte ihnen
vorstellen herzlich willkommen bei bild
verbringt hat
jetzt schon gesagt sie haben es
geschafft olaf scholz zum wahlsieger zu
machen mit ihren plakaten schaffen sie
es dann auch im verweigerer ungeimpfte
zum impfen zu bringen dazu ein
sowohl bei der spd aufgabe als auch
jetzt beim kampf gegen korona ist es eh
was der teamleistung und ich glaube gebe
ich die akw im team sind ihr besser wer
als nationen zusammenhalten umso
einfacher und besser werden wie auch
diese krise bewältigen ein phänomen
scheint mir zu sein dass je öfter die
regierung sagt lasst euch bitte impfen
um so mehr sagen hunderttausende
vielleicht millionen menschen ihr könnt
mich mal das machen wir dann erst recht
nicht wenn ihr uns dazu auffordert
stimmt das und wie kriegt man solche
leute
ich glaube man muss unterscheiden
zwischen redaktioneller kommunikation
und werbliche kommunikation und was
nicht hilft ist der zeigefinger was
nicht hilft ist
moralapostel zu sein so ärgern muss man
gucken wie kommando über das herz jetzt
in dem fall zum kriegs und wie kann man
die menschen die herzen der menschen
erobern und das macht man nicht durch
ein zeigefinger sondern das macht man
durch die kampagne die einlädt die
unterhält die mit frischen ideen kommt
und die begeistert vielleicht und ich
glaube da können wir viel von anderen
nationen lernt gerade ich sehen was
aufgefallen im ausland ich habe mehr
austragen das beispiel im letzten jahr
gesehen als wir über aha regeln
gesprochen abend das
gesundheitsministerium in tokio hat zum
damaligen zeitpunkt
auf dass die abstandsregeln aufmerksam
gemacht indem sie einmal ein
tischtennisball mit 500 mausefallen
praktisch zueinander gebracht hat einmal
auf ganz geringen abstand er löste diese
einen baum alle 500 mausefallen aus und
einmal hat man die mausefalle sind
auseinander gezogen und dann gingen nur
wenige auf und besser könnte man aus
meiner sicht nicht dann erstellen welche
folgen es hat wenn wir keinen bestand
haben sie vielleicht noch eine konkrete
idee wieso eine kampagne jetzt aussehen
könnte von der regierung von der politik
von wem auch immer um eben das herz der
ungeimpften zu treffen jetzt geht es
darum die skeptiker zu gewinnen und das
macht man durch eine kampagne die nicht
nur regeln verboten hat sondern
insbesondere auch aufklärt noch mal
lieber tatsächlich risiken und
nebenwirkungen und dass er gemacht und
ich glaube diese wir müssen mut haben zu
dieser einfachen sprache was wir noch
machen müssen ist sowas wie zb weimarer
bürger gemacht haben gerade eine
kampagne gestartet habe immenstadt
schimpfen oder aber das wird so etwas
machen wie der beste schutz ist der
impfschutz oder wie wir es bei der spd
gemacht haben ein kleiner pieks für dich
ein großer schritt zur normalität wir
haben eine sehnsucht nach alltag und
nach normalität vor kronen und diese
sehnsucht können wir glaube ich gut
befriedigen durch bilder die diese
geschichten erzählen wenn der
gesundheitsminister jetzt gleich rein
käme bei bild und sagen würde wenn ich
das höre herr brink art machen sie mir
die kampagne würden sie sagen ja oder
nein
ich würde sie in dem fall sogar
kostenlos machen weil wir als agentur
sehr deutlich sagen dass wir uns nach
mobilität sehen und dass dieses land
eine bessere kommunikation verdient hat
wow das ist eine ansage verbringt hat
vielen dank für das gespräch kostenlose
kampagne fürs impfen aus ihrem hause wir
warten auf die antwort von ersparen
alles klar wie sich bei danke herzlichen
dank herr
statt sie zu überzeugen hat die
regierung ungeimpfte monatelang
ausgegrenzt deswegen noch mal die
eine-million-euro-frage der deutschen
corona politik schafft man es jetzt noch
tatsächlich massenweise ungeimpfte zur
impfung zu bewegen ich sage leider nein
dafür ist es zu spät die impfquote die
wird nicht mehr massiv steigen und wir
müssen das akzeptieren ohne hass ohne
dass freundschaften enden ohne
ausgrenzung ohne spaltung
hunderttausende menschen in deutschland
sind um geimpft und wollen es bleiben